Continental Tire Coach's Corner Sixers
head coach Brett Brown joins us coach we
were just talking music to start the
show who controls the music in the
locker room with the Sixers I think your
alum bead and then sort of other
resident DJ's as it sits in Philadelphia
but I thought Redick is an actual rapper
so I would think that JJ reddick would
have seniority and the fact that he is a
rapper he's got a strong presence for
sure and I bet he has more of a say than
I am aware of but ya know we we let him
have fun the locker room has a good vibe
to it if I let you control the music
what are we listening to I'd go to old
dire straits or old Bruce Springsteen
I think migos probably rules today and I
Sherlock robot I go back to my roots and
some you know old dire straights Mark
Knopfler and old Bruce Springsteen of my
passion maybe some Rolling Stones
have you seen Springsteen oh yeah
still amazing you know I was just in New
York a month and a half ago and you know
just to sit here and it's sort of like
you're in a living room with him and he
tells his stories and he connects it to
songs and I followed him for you know
three and a half decades so I you know
big fan and I just find him amazingly
entertaining because he still so fit
he's incredible shape he drinks you know
water after water after water and he
brings it he just has amazing energy and
so yes to your question I saw him a
month and a half ago in New York oh that
Broadway show yeah and like he really
it's like you're in a living room with
him you know there's 700 people and you
just sit and let him talk and it's very
interactive maybe invite him to it to a
game I mean he lives an hour away yeah
well I know coach Riley back in his heat
days was a very connected I mean with
Clarence Clemons before Clarence passed
away and
you know with the Boston in coach Riley
he had a connection that's not a bad
idea
I would if he came I let him draw up the
first place well how tough would that be
you either get it to em beat or let Ben
Simmons take it right yeah yes you know
it's at times it's not much more
complicated than that okay but let's go
back because people forget what you went
through and we had you on during this
process did you ever have one of those
or the last time you had one of those
moments where you just you know what it
got to you where you just said I I just
don't know if I'm gonna see the light at
the end of the tunnel I mean during the
ten win season and you know you lost 26
in a row and we had multiple injuries
and we really haven't had much good
fortune here in Philadelphia without
first draft picks either playing at all
for an entire season or staying healthy
for the large majority of it I think
during that period of time you know you
wanted did you you know times was it
something that you thought you were
signing up for and we all sort of have a
coaching mortality on the son of a coach
and so you recognize you know the
industry and you know yes to your
question of course and I did feel
comfortable and confident we were
working on the correct things my version
of what I think a culture is when it
would it wouldn't wouldn't reflect like
winning and losing which is what
everybody sort of looks at you know what
times you you you would you know have
some late nights but when the last time
I spoke with you compared to where we
are now that seems like a long time ago
you went from ten to fifty two wins in
two years I mean that's pretty terrible
there did you ever worry did you ever
think you were getting fired oh yeah you
know you always thought about it like I
I think the relationship that I had with
with the owners in regards to what the
plan was like they brought me into New
York City five years ago
and they said this is a wish you know
how do we rebuild a culture how do we
start from Ground Zero and rebuild it
and at that stage for me I was what
fifty three years old and I'd been lucky
to be with pop for twelve years and seen
what like five championships look like
and was a head coach for seventeen years
prior I had a strong opinion of what I
thought a culture should look like and
so you know we were able to walk some
stuff down along the path it would
definitely some rough bumps but I did
feel connected with the vision I felt
connected with the owners you know and
they to their credit Josh Harris and
David Blitzer have delivered on what
they told me they were going to do and
so here you know here we are let's get
to the business now you got the heat
tomorrow night JoEllen bead status for
game one is he will he will not play in
Game one okay you know he will not play
in Game one and uh you know from that
point going forward you know we'll we'll
figure some stuff out but uh unless
something remarkable happens Dan you
know I I don't you know I don't plan on
him playing in Game one
Markel volts and how much he plays how
do you lean on him yeah probably in the
same capacity that I've lent on him
since he has come back the decision for
him to return you know is he going to
help or hurt the team he's 19 years old
he hasn't played NBA basketball the
risk/reward was always present you had
to make a decision and I felt like the
reward was going to tilt over the risk
and and we've been proven right and so I
feel like I'm gonna continue on with how
I played him primarily has been Simmons
backup point guard and you know judge it
from me and he had a triple-double the
other night I think he's trending in the
way that we had all hoped albeit very
late in a very serious part of the NBA
season but I intended on using him going
into the playoffs that way why is it it
feels like we still were missing a
chapter in this book on marquel Foltz
with his shot
I think you asked that question
differently I think I know what you're
saying and asked it differently please
why don't what don't I know I think you
do know I think I think everybody
searches for like this clandestine you
know conspiracy theory and it's clear he
was injured and he his shot you know
took a hit I'm sure there were times
that he was aware of that in his mind
he's the first player chosen you know
Philadelphia isn't sort of a you know
warm and fuzzy marketplace and I think
it's just like human nature exacerbated
by a injury to a shoulder and the good
news is out of all the years that I've
been coached and I've been doing this a
long time did this this this the human
side of this story is is incredibly
endearing to me he's a remarkable person
you know like you want to hug him as
much as you want to coach him he's just
really good people and so to fast
forward like and go through all this
stuff he went through and now he's
playing NBA basketball in his last you
know game he had a triple-double the
youngest in the history of the NBA
like those are the memories stand that I
would like to marketplace to hear and
and that's the truth you know like
that's all the whole thing sort of
unfolded yeah I felt bad for him at this
video almost like surveillance video of
his shot and then it came out and then I
was saying gosh I just hope you guys
shut him down so he's not subjected to
this because it felt like he lost
confidence in that shot and you can even
watch him as great as he is to get a
triple-double I'm still looking at do
defenses respect that jump shot right
now and they probably don't and you know
that's all fear you know I hear you and
I think that's all fear and so be it
it's uh and the NBA playoffs are so
incredibly different in the regular
season to beat somebody four times and
you know have to game plan each game
gets a little bit more granular in the
secrets become less and less and so you
know the judgment of how they guard mark
Kellogg
you know we're gonna see some stuff it's
different than rolling into a city you
know an 82-game regular season and we
will learn but uh given where he was and
given where he is we're very happy both
for him and for the organization he has
helped this team well Congrats you don't
strike me if you were on pop staff of
caring about award so hopefully you get
strong consideration for Coach of the
year but more importantly good luck in
the playoffs no thanks for having me Dan
good to speak with you and that's Brett
Brown these Sixers head coach for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]